now the mound for the astros today is
right-hander jake odorizzi owner is a
four and six with a 4.95 erin run
average in 15 games 14 starts
swinging a miss odarizi gets a high
fastball for a swinging strike and we're
underway with an odor izzy strikeout to
start this game now here's ryan mcmahon
and that ball over the shift and into
the right field corner over the head of
taylor jones kyle tucker will dig it out
of the corner thinking about three the
throw from altuve will be
in time
tucker to altuve to diaz to nail ryan
mcmahon trying to stretch a double into
a triple
good team defense right there helping
out jake odorizzi
everything just perfect tucker with the
throw then out to the with a long
hop to the third baseman and diaz
deaking
the sliding runner at third base with
the late tag that was beautiful that was
really well done
you can see how close it was diaz just
slapping the tag on the thigh of mcmahon
before he hit the bag
and that's a broken bat hit off the
hands correa to his left makes the ken's
shoulder high so odor izzy gives up a
double that faces the minimum thanks to
an outfield assist john making his 21st
start his last day in particular been
great at 285 earned run average so here
he goes for the first time
at minute maid park
and the fastball up is hit in the air to
shallow center it's dying now and a good
recovery by sam hilliard never
underestimate closing speed
2-2 pitch to diaz swag and a miss he
goes upstairs with the fastball to get
his first strikeout
swung on it miss so gray with a couple
of strikeouts and a solid first inning
here's kyle tucker and they're climbing
the ladders john with the good heater
he's definitely got that tonight three
strikeouts
of the five outs that'll bring up chaz
mccormick
we got it
into center field by mccormick well hit
all the way back and that's off the wall
chas heading into second and he'll go
sliding with a double hit well to
straight away center two outs here's the
one two he got him on the swing jones is
gone good job by
john gray to get that third out after
the double by mccormick it's a two-two
count two outs nobody on odarizi is set
here's the pitch and he got it by him
again strike three
that was the fastball third
punch out for odor rizzy and we played
two and a half it's the rockies nothing
the astros nothing for the houston
astros against john gray it'll be
martine maldonado then altuve and
brantley
and he got him on a slider
so john with his fifth strikeout already
very impressive first run through the
lineup he gets five strikeouts and this
team does not swing and miss
chased upstairs john has struck out
three in a row six strikeouts and
that'll bring up michael brantley get
him on a ground ball to hampson great
work by gray six strikeouts through
three innings bottom of the fourth
inning no score with the rockies and
astros ground ball base hit there it is
olympus diaz
first lead off base runner of an inning
for the astros as he leads off with a
single in the left
this one off the foot of gray it's going
to make its way into the outfield
that'll be a base hit for carlos correa
that might be what the doctor ordered
you go from deflation of a hard-hit
baseball with the potential being a
double play and it ends up being a knock
and john is piling up the strikeouts
that's number eight here's mccormick
mccormick saw one pitch from gray in his
first at bat and drilled it to straight
away center field off of the wall
there's a line drive up the middle base
hit dsb and wave tone the throw by
hilliard will be cut off correa in the
third astros lead one to nothing
chaz mccormick comes through with an rbi
it's been the only one that's been able
to figure out that slider from john gray
so runners on the corners now for taylor
jones
that falls a shot down the line and
right fair ball in the score correa
mccormick's going to be waved around he
is going to be safe taylor jones is
going to go to third the ball's loose
astros lead this game three to nothing
taylor jones two rbis ends up on third
base and the astros lead it three
nothing taylor jones hitting a rocket
down the right field line the astros
finally getting to john gray and doing
it with two strikes as that fastball
misses its spot
two on maldonado
got him on a slider that is his ninth
strikeout but damage done so one on two
out connor joe the batter this ball up
the middle what a play out
his throw in time wow
maybe his finest player of the year jose
altuve
ranges up the middle to throw out connor
joe to end the inning
jose altuve stands in against john gray
oh for two tonight oh look out
that caught out too they on a 3-2 pitch
yeah you just kind of hope that
got that elbow pad but i'm not sure he
got that elbow pad
oh it wasn't down far enough caught the
end of the elbow that's not going to
feel good not at all we'll bring up
michael brantley brantley drives one
towards right center field this ball is
off the base of the wall altuve to third
he'll be waved around the relay throw
won't be made altuve scores on the rbi
double by michael brantley it's a
four-nothing game
we've been talking all game about how
good the numbers are for
michael brantley against john great he
got him on this one
in the dirt ball four so that's the
second walk issued by gray three of the
four batters he's faced this inning have
reached and here comes manager bud black
and takes the baseball from john gray
stevenson 30th appearance second
appearance since
coming off the injured list 0-1 pitch
breaking ball hit the second hampson to
story for juan onda first for the double
play good job by robert stevenson the
twin kill
gets the rockies out of the inning jones
back at second for altuve who's over two
he's been hit by a pitch
and he hooks one towards left this
follows down for a hit taylor jones
being waved in the throw by connor joe a
little bit late
astros add to their lead on the rbi
single by jose altuve it's five to
nothing
got a breaking ball had to go out and
around to get this one but of course in
jose altuve fashion he finds plenty of
open grass out there in left field to
drop this in front of connor joe made a
good turn on it and good throw but
taylor jones was going to beat it by
plenty ends up hitting him in the back
as he knocks it down chaz mccormick
leads off here bottom half of the eighth
inning 2-2 pitch is hit in the air to
left field into that corner and up
against the fence making the catch is
connor joe good play by connor
yeah reaching up right in front of the
366 sign
yeah it and there it is just a
square corner where those boxes end
there's no angle astral's debut for
pedro baez here he is been his entire
career since 2014 with the los angeles
dodgers
got him on a good change up down and
away striking out hilliard
baez picks up his first strikeout in a
uniform other than the dodgers
and a ground ball towards third diaz to
altuve for one the double play turn in
time ball game over
astros win it five to nothing
it is a five
combined shutout
baez will start the handshake line in
his first outing as a houston astro
you